اقف هنا في صينيه اسماعيل الازهري وهذا
منزل اول رئيس وزراء للحكومه السودان في
هذه المنطقه ليست ببعيده من جسر شامبات
الرابط بين
هذا
الجسم وعسكري يدفع لقوات الدعم السريع
قوات الدعم السريع وتتمركز في هذا الجسر
الان وليس في بعيده من هذه المنطقه
الطريقه الاخر من هنا يؤدي الى الهيئه
القوميه للاذاعه والتلفزيون التي تتجدد
فيها الاشتباكات في مدينه ام درمان ربما
هذه المنطقه الان كما نراها هادئه لكن
السكان هنا يشكون من هلع وتوتر بحكم ان
هذه المنطقه بالتحديد يسمع فيها اصوات ذوي
للمدافع الثقيله والخفيفه وفي هذه المنطقه
بالضبط يسمع ايضا مضادات او طائرات بين
الفينه والاخرى اصبحت خاليه تماما من
السكان الا نذرا يسيرا وهم الان يحذروننا
من الوقوف في هذه المنطقه بقناتي العربيه
والحدث سالم الهاشمي من مدينه ام درمان
لمتابعه المزيد
الوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات